in 2013 he hosted joe rogan questions
everything on the sci-fi channel which
sci-fi gave him the the show without
even doing a pilot they just said hey
we're going to give you control
it only lasted a season but then in 2000
and then uh and then you know because he
he got the show on the on the sci-fi
channel but he was talking about stuff
on his podcast
and i think that people just liked his
podcast better than the sci-fi channel
thing
because the joe rogan experience
initially i didn't realize this either
like you stream
he started it with with yeah with brian
redband and then
it was just like he was like look we
just started out initially to be like
we're on a laptop [ __ ] and [ __ ]
around talking about conspiracy theories
so if you listen to the original joe
rogan episodes it's really just a couple
of guys
just being silly willy and then by 2015
it was getting downloaded by
16 million people an episode i mean he's
[ __ ] actually amazing joey
when did it turn from like that ustream
show to the studio that not that many
years only a couple of years
because i remember he used to stream it
and it wasn't that many years ago
so i think probably half of the time i
mean it started in 2009
um it was it was kind of like i remember
he would do it he would stream it
they were on a couch in the living room
i remember
a guest and he was just sitting on a
couch the studio is not that many years
old
and the podcast has evolved from like
they would smoke weed and like joke
around and stuff like that
to him now like interviewing uh like
astrophysicists
astronauts uh you know titans of
industry
scientists uh and then everything
changed when you got to say probably
when he interviewed bernie sanders
it really hit the mainstream i mean the
kid the kid's name now
trends like at least once a week or
something yeah now it's like then you
had elon musk
famously yeah i mean yeah yeah must puff
the [ __ ]
elon this is how you know how powerful
how much how big the reach got is elon
musk shared a joint with them and then
uh it affected tesla's stock yeah one
thousand nine stocks
nine percent because the kid took a pump
on it which is also like come on
i mean the truth is and joe rogan now
just picks and chooses what guess he
wants rightfully so but it's like
if he had whatever presidential
candidate does better on the joe roger
show is who will win
he was offered some mtv gig early on
he's like he just didn't want to do it i
want to do this was before he was big
and he turned it down yeah because he
started
no but but look yeah before he's big
because a lot you know look when he
started the podcast in 2009 i'm sure he
already had a lot of money because he
was already
doing fear factor and all that but that
even more so to say
he started the joe rogan podcast just
because he wanted to do it he didn't
need to do it no
so that's why he has all that he has
because he's not
following the money he's not following
anything else but his own heart
furthermore people
people were saying because he it's like
a three hour podcast yeah and he
he does it like three or four of them a
week and people are going hey it's way
too long he was doing that at a time
where everyone was going shorter yeah
and going like your clip's too long it
clips too long eclipse too long
eclipse too long uh he went the other
way and just went long he's like this is
what i want to do and then he started
interviewing what you would think are
boring people
going like who wants to sit there and
listen to an astrophysicist
but you know i always thought the
opposite i always when i used to watch
those late night shows i'd be like
why the [ __ ] do i care what natalie
portman ever has to say
right she's a woman who has a career
reading the lines of other people
in a make-believe story right i would
rather listen to
an astrophysicist or an astronaut for
two hours
answer interesting questions it's almost
like he does the podcast for himself
because if you listen to it he's such an
intrigued guy he's so
curious that he has people on yeah who
he's
interested in he doesn't care about the
ratings anymore but he turns down
celebrities all the time he doesn't want
to do i understand like
like publishers will call because they
know how big it is now and be like do
you want to have
uh this actor on he's like no he just
says no
yeah just he goes like i'd rather talk
to joey cocodiaz about [ __ ] and i'd
rather listen to joey coco diaz so he
just does what he
he kind of does what he wants ufc it was
a passion thing dude
when he started as a ufc commentator
dana white offered him the gig
um and he turned it down at first
because he said he just wanted to go to
the fights
and drink so he said no at first then um
he did it the first time in exchange for
free tickets right that's how small the
ufc was
so dana white gave him like free tickets
for him and his boys and he did it for
free and then he ended up being a
commentator
for free for a little while yeah how
long was it he was actually doing it for
free
until for a little while and then
finally he accepted our he liked it and
so he accepted money
for doing it yeah so for a while he did
it for free yeah i mean you know
joey railro i mean it's just like i mean
and dude
that goes down in history we really hope
you enjoyed that episode whatever it was
about this is just a stock thing that
we're taping on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild
[Music]